j'ai la peau d'orange suisse
il y des gens pour se réunir si longo
quoi qu'est ce que c'est ah bonjour
françois bonjour casimir même casimir tu
vas la pêche
non je vais à la pêche aux oxmoze soit
vous la question idiote réponse est
idiote
j'avoue que tu as raison casimir avec
tout un attirail j'aurais pu éviter de
se poser une telle question
tu vois ce n'est pas toujours moi qui
fais les erreurs non feint que j mur
j'ai jamais dit ça puis tu sais tout le
monde peut se tenter un même les
personnes les plus intelligentes et
aucune honte à ça a parfois atteint une
erreur à françois a fait une erreur
françois garrec situe aussi drôle à
chaque fois que je dis une bêtise je
crois que je vais dire de quoi plus ils
ont prévenir du péché dans l'eau dans le
dos à sa chance serait douté mais tu a
péché dans le nez ou dans l'eau de
rivière non non la mer est trop loin
alors je vais là-bas dans la rivière
annaba et cure et ubs attend regarde oui
je vais pêcher tout ça tout ça et vingt
dix dons mais casimir qui va jeûner
pouvoir manger autant de poissons à mai
mais ce n'est pas du tout pour les
manger c'est pour le nouvel aquarium de
l'île aux enfants c'est très bien ça
qu'est signalant tu vas capturer les
poissons afin que les enfants puissent
aller les admirer ouais c'est formidable
et une question de poissons et bien
regarde il y à une murène prague aux
jeunes gens apprennent tôt ostermann au
top casimir que l'émir attendant
nathalie les enfants et agnes qu'est-ce
qui va faner rené venez bien carole
voilà ce qui se passe aurélie casimir il
a des problèmes
casimir s'en va à la pêche mais il a
tout mélangé les poissons de mer les
poissons d'eau douce a alors on va
l'aider comme honteux vous êtes d'accord
bien attention casimir danuta liste
alors j'ai d'abord une murène une murène
une murène est ce que c'est un poisson
d'eau de mer ou impression de rivière
à votre avis un un poisson de mer une
murène certains poissons de mer c'est ça
un goujon un beau jour un poisson de
rivière et beaux jours at on a tort
c'est un poisson de mer
l'unaf hall à une seule mère un poisson
de l1 branchait rivière buisson
formidable devenir une vraie un poisson
de mails de mer ah bon un maquereau anna
cros un poisson de mer
tu as vu ils répondent tous ces mois de
suite allé après une prime une brême 1-1
impression de rivières la brême est un
poisson de rivière
après bon elle n'est ce pas dans n
est-ce pas d'eau un poisson de mer c'est
ça ah bon annick durgeon 1 1 nice
sergent anesthésiant
un poisson de mer non cette impression
de rivière à laisser aux gens le fruit
d'un impôt son droit à un piranha
piranha caramia à d'iraniens y est une
bête très très féroces gagneurs
après un bar un bar un turbo à terme
devenir apprécions derrière ta poissons
de mer ensuite donc fait une otan ch une
tanche alors une poche mais rivière une
tanche river rivière dans la vie à jean
françois et pour terminer un sous mon
aile saumon à vous avez tous entendu
c'est un peu les deux c'est à dire que
le saumon vit dans la mer mais tous les
ans à l'automne
il remonte le cours de la rivière pour
aller faire ses petits voilà et kazimiya
comment vas-tu attraper toutes et
poissons rabbin et voilà j'ai ma canne à
pêche m'ont épuisé
et puis ça qu'est ce que c'est que ça
vous ne devinez pas d'un autre c'est pas
facile
bon alors je vais vous expliquer ça
c'est pour les pieuvres on mais
l'entonnoir dans l'eau la pieuvre
s'approche elle voit les huit morceaux
de pain alors elle met ses huit
tentacules dans l'entonnoir
et puis quand elle a attrapé les huit
morceaux demain à lui dire mais elle ne
peut plus sortir
alors on sort l'entonnoir de l'eau avec
la pieuvre est d'abord bloqué zini mal
de bricoles à l'artiste y est ce que tu
vas à bâle à une petite souris est vite
vite vite au monde sur le banc exil à
faire avec ta souris la gazinière
vous ne vivez pas là non
la dèche et non ça c'est pour attraper
les poissons chats voilà et ensuite
qu'est ce que d'ailleurs doit ensuite
j'ai cette chose là
ah bravo notre masse à une ampoule un
interrupteur et une prise que tu vas
faire vexin et bien je mets le fil
darlot humaine fils dans l'eau et
lorsqu'il aura électrique c'est pour les
ré electric electric mort laprise l'art
et hop la lampe s'allume et l'autre à
nine jeu qui attire voile a été repêché
par électrique
c'est formidable bon et puis on a encore
une chose encore et voilà ça un gros
clous y est qu'est ce que c'est d'alcool
alors qu'est ce que fabriquent avec ça
alors on met le clou dans l'eau actuelle
coup dans l'eau l'obtient le fnal fils
tu tiens le film je mets de la colle sur
la tête du cloud
raïssi le requin-marteau harris et pour
les requins marteaux cabinet y donner un
coup il a collé sur le cloud et je tire
voilà et ça y est j'ai pêché à notre
place aux îles dont casimir c'est très
bien tout ça mais j'aime tout ennui doit
quoi le requin-marteau l'art électrique
le poisson-chat la pieuvre tout ça on
les trouvera dans la rivière c'est ça et
casimir va pêcher dans la rivière qui
est la leur mais je ne suis pas si bête
que ça en fait j'ai pensé à tout voilà
et tu as trouvé une solution
- et quelle est la solution la voilà la
solution celle de mr ouai et commodité
je met du sel dans la rivière et tous
les poissons crois que c'est la mer